the series may be hurtling toward the
finish line but fast X still sets aside
some time to nod towards its roots from
mixing up the formula to some very
familiar quotes here are some of the
best callbacks in fast X
DX spends a lot of time calling back to
the events of Fast Five Chief among them
is Dante Reyes is the son of Hernan
Reyes appropriately the movie opens with
a Redux of the Fast Five climax in which
Dom and Brian steal the ray is safe this
time though Dante is there if you
haven't seen the fifth film in a while
you might not notice just how close fast
X slots him into the action the car he
drives during the bridge battle the one
with the minigun that pops out of the
top is pulled straight from the original
scene this creates a fun time Loop
moment for anyone who goes back to Fast
Five in the future the later parts of
fast X also make reference to Dante's
retconned Fast 5 Cameo he has a base of
operations in the abandoned police
station where Dom and Brian stole the
safe and he ambushes Dom on the very
same Bridge thus reversing his previous
defeat there
typically Fast and Furious movies end
with a family barbecue scene fastx
changes things up by starting with one
instead this is an early clue that
things aren't going to go well in the
third act because the movie ends on a
huge Cliffhanger with the lives of
multiple major characters hanging in the
balance there's no room for a feel-good
finale the opening cookout is still full
of fun little details though the whole
gang can be seen sipping on Coronas
which have been The Unofficial official
beer of Fast and Furious since the
beginning you can have any Brew you want
as long as it's a Corona and Roman once
again tries to sneak some food before
the blessing has been said just as he
has many times before there's also a
cute moment between Little Brian and
Letty when Dom walks into the barbecue
with his son after their driving lesson
Brian gives Letty a hug and calls her
mom Letty may not actually be Brian's
blood mother but she's raised him as her
own since he was incredibly young it's
nice to see how their relationship is
blossomed and the little glimpse of
tenderness from Letty is a perfect
character moment
during the cookout scene at the
beginning of fast X Dom and Han share a
moment of reflection on their thieving
Origins as Han says we've come a long
way from flipping fuel trucks in the Dr
this is a direct reference to the
beginning of Fast and Furious the fourth
film in the franchise in which Dom Han
Letty Leo and Santos pulled various
small-time heists in the Dominican
Republic to make ends meet their stint
there culminated in a field truck
robbery gone horribly wrong the first
big action set piece of Fast and Furious
as they reminisce Han offers a toast
saying Los Bandoleros for Life Los
Bandoleros is the name of the short film
prequel to Fast and Furious which
details how the Dr crew was first
assembled the Dominican Republic stories
are technically Han's earliest entry in
the Fast and Furious timeline not
counting Justin Lin's film better luck
tomorrow which serves as an unofficial
prequel of sorts and of course Vin
Diesel himself actually directed Los
Bandoleros making the reference extra
special for Dom as well
right after his Los Bandoleros
reminiscing with Han Dom takes a moment
to glance around his garage and take
note of the many family photos he's
tacked up on the walls the camera
lingers on several of him and Brian
together and as it does the piano
refrain of SEO again Blends in with the
original score The Wiz Khalifa and
Charlie puth Anthem was written to
commemorate the late Paul Walker and it
became a massive hit in its own right
after debuting at the emotional end of
Furious 7. the fast franchise has always
handled Walker's Legacy with tact and
respect choosing to leave him out of the
story rather than recast the role or
bring him back with CGI even in a movie
like Fast X where Brian's absence
doesn't really affect the story it's
nice to see Diesel and the crew still
take a moment to pay homage to his life
and career
after the opening barbecue Dom gets
vulnerable about his fears he admits
being scared of losing Brian or Letty
and she tells him that won't happen
again this is a two-for-one reference
calling back to both letty's almost
death and fast and furious and the time
Brian was kidnapped by Cipher in the
fate of the Furious in letty's case she
lost her memory and was out of the
picture for two whole movies only
getting brought back into the fold by a
persistent Dom in Fast and Furious 6.
Brian was likely too young during his
captivity to remember much of it in
detail but we see later in fast X how
the trauma of the experience still
affects him later on in the movie we get
another nod to let his brief time
working for Owen Shaw when Tess visits
her in prison she points out a scar on
letty's arm that she got the night she
first met Dom thereby proving that he
sent her this is the exact same Scar and
story that Dom uses to convince Letty of
their history in Fast and Furious 6.
in any Fast and Furious movie there are
going to be some standout cars sometimes
the vehicles driven by the crew are
simply chosen because they look neat but
sometimes they have a deeper meaning to
start Cipher enters the film behind the
wheel of a DeLorean Alpha 5. a yet to be
released limited edition homage to the
DeLorean Motor Company's Heyday with the
iconic dmc-12 the back to the futuristic
look of the car is fitting for Cipher's
techno-terrorist aesthetic and since the
car isn't out yet it's safe to assume
that she stole one during the big action
sequence in Rome Han drives a boxy Alfa
Romeo with an orange and black color
scheme it's the exact same coloring that
his Mazda RX7 has in the Fast and the
Furious Tokyo Drift and of course Jacob
gets to drive his old blue 5.0 fox body
Mustang which was first seen during the
flashback scenes in F9 the fast Saga
Jacob references his drag race with dom
while talking to little Brian and he
also mentions how cool it was to have a
5.0 back in the day clearly Brian isn't
all that impressed by Mustangs as his
project car shown earlier in the movie
is actually a Chevy SS given that his
dad loves Dodge and his uncle loves Ford
it feels right that the kid goes with a
third major American car manufacturer
the first big action set piece in fast X
takes place in Rome during a mission led
by appropriately Roman he Han tej and
Ramsay are tricked by Dante into
stealing a bomb believing that the
operation has been commissioned by the
agency through it all Roman constantly
asserts his own abilities as a leader
and takes offense every time the others
doubt his chops while not necessarily an
intentional reference this little Arc
for Roman is interesting given his
history in The Saga he first appeared in
Too Fast Too Furious as the replacement
for Vin Diesel who opted to film The
Chronicles of Riddick instead in another
timeline that could have led to Tyrese
Gibson being one of the two leading
co-stars for the series and Roman quite
literally being the leader of the crew
but instead the character became comic
relief under Dom's Shadow for fans of
the too fast era it's fun to see Roman
getting a bit of development on the
leadership end Gibson is still more than
capable of stealing scenes on his own
and he gets some solid material in fast
X there is a more specific too fast
reference later when Roman reveals that
he keeps cash strapped to himself under
his clothes he pulls the exact same move
at the end of the second film
the Rome sequence of fastx is
action-packed but it also includes a
number of smaller references to the
earlier Fast and Furious films as part
of the Caper Ramsay winds up behind the
wheel of a big truck carrying a piece of
dangerous Tech in this case a giant bomb
this seems like a clear nod to the
Edinburgh sequence in F9 the fast Saga
in which she was forced to drive a truck
carrying a super magnet Letty also
chooses to gear up on a motorcycle
instead of in a regular car which is
another nod to F9 during the Minefield
sequence of that film she's shown to be
a master both behind the wheel and
behind the handlebars and as is only
right when putting Han inside an orange
and black sports car he does a bit of
drifting for the camera hearkening back
to his time in Tokyo
more than any other piece of The Fast
and Furious story fast X seems fixated
on the Vault Heist from the end of Fast
Five it opens by reliving the chase
through Dante's eyes it returns to the
very same police station and Bridge
later on and it pays homage to the scene
on several other occasions the bomb
Chase in Rome is an obvious nod to the
safe robbery Dante himself acknowledges
this claiming to have set it up as an
homage to his family's downfall what he
doesn't mention is that Dom drives a
Dodge Charger Hellcat during the Rome
sequence A variation of the exact same
cars that he and Brian used to pull the
vault in Fast Five in the wake of the
bomb's explosion Tess also alludes to
the Vault Heist after Dom chastises her
for carrying God's eye on her person she
says people pull vaults out of walls so
I think it's safer with me as if that
weren't enough fast X drops one more
Vault Chase reference during its own
fiery climax as he chases down Dante in
Little Brian Dom is attacked by two
helicopters that fire grappling hooks
into his car and try to lift him off the
road his car gets out just enough
horsepower to yank both Choppers down in
flames and he uses the them both as
makeshift melee weapons just like he
once did with the vault
if there's one thing Fast and Furious
movies love to do it's quote the
original and a little ways into the
second act of fast X Little Brian does
just that after he beats his aunt Mia in
a round of Hot Wheels Unleashed she
jokingly chastises him Brian responds
with his own version of this famous
quote it it don't matter if you went
into our mind
the first time Brian references that
particular scene from the first movie
after his driving lesson with dom at the
beginning of the film the little guy is
frustrated that he can't quite get
things right he almost had it his dad
says but Brian responds I didn't have it
this is yet another part of that famous
scene between Brian O'Connor and Dom
after losing their first street race
against each other Brian tells Dom dude
almost had you
[Applause]
you never had your car even when the
Vatican is being bombed and armies of
cyber Commandos are at the door Fast and
Furious still makes time for some good
old street racing
in fastx Dom travels back to Rio to
confront Dante Reyes and they end up
meeting at a racing event very similar
to the ones seen in Fast Five in fact
one of the local characters in that film
Diogo returns and backstom up when Dante
appears mirroring the face off between
Hobbes and Dom in Fast Five we get
another little callback during the race
itself the Yogo gets a bit too antsy and
Pops as NOS early making him a Target in
Dante's Twisted game the too soon
nitrous moment is a classic of the
franchise going all the way back to Dom
and Brian's first drag this time though
the mistake is extra deadly
as it turns out Isabelle is actually the
sister of Elena Nevis the latent mother
of Little Brian who was killed by Cipher
in the fate of the furious Dom sees her
from Dante's bomb and takes her back to
Elena's old apartment where Isabelle now
lives she confesses to him how much
guilt she used to feel over Elena dying
instead of her since her sister was
always the good one and Isabelle saw
herself as bad in response Dom explains
how much Common Ground there can be
between a cop and a street racer when
they go down the same road long enough
clearly this is a reference to his
relationship with Brian which began when
the latter was investigating him for DVD
player robberies while undercover over
time Brian abandoned his law enforcement
career to become a full-time Crook and
brother to Dom
one of the best storylines in fast X is
the uncle nephew road trip that Jacob
goes on with little Brian it's a fun
light-hearted distraction from the heavy
action of the film and it yields one
particularly poignant moment between the
two characters
nope not that one well on the trip Brian
admits that he doesn't like planes
prompting his uncle to share how he was
once terrified of cars after the
accident that killed his father of
course the reason little B is so
frightened of planes is he was
imprisoned on one as a baby in a movie
where Cipher becomes a begrudging Ally
this little moment reminds us of just
how vile she truly is she forever
changed the course of Brian's Life by
taking his mothers in the fate of the
Furious and though she and Letty have
set a temporary truce she'll have to
answer for her crimes eventually
the climax Chase sequence of fast X has
a few notable nods to the series past
for instance when Dom enters The Fray he
airdrops out of the back of a cargo
plane although the fastex drop is much
lower it might remind viewers of the
multi-car airdrop in Furious 7 which
actually involved parachutes at this
point Dominic Toretto is a true veteran
of driving muscle cars out of airplanes
later during the standoff atop the dam
Dom is forced to drive straight down the
face of the structure in order to save
Brian whose writing in the passenger
seat he barely outruns the explosion
caused by Dante thanks in large part to
him hitting the nitrous at the exact
right moment this triggers a CGI NOS
infusion shot that Harkens back to the
series roots
fastx ends with two big twists first
Giselle appears in the nuclear submarine
from the fate of the Furious to rescue
Letty and Cipher from Antarctica after
that there's a mid-credit scene in which
Dwayne Johnson's Luke Hobbs makes his
triumphant return to the fast Saga both
reveals are shocking but for different
reasons hobb's appearance is surprising
because of behind the scenes issues
while giselle's is surprising because
well she died even so her return is
foreshadowed by a couple different
moments throughout the film during the
opening cookout tejan Roman helped Han
make a dating profile but his heart
clearly isn't in it later while speaking
with Tess Ames mentions that the Toretto
crew was involved in the heist of a
nuclear submarine letting the audience
know that the vessel was never recovered
paves the way for it to pop back up at
the end of the movie